in the backyard or the beach smith's has
the perfect recipe for an
outdoor feast hello everybody i'm chef
jeff from smith's okay today i have an
awesome recipe that's perfect for any
summer barbecue any get-together of any
kind that makes use of
maybe some fresh vegetables you have in
your garden and if not
get some fresh vegetables at your local
smiths they'll have all these
ingredients there for you
so let's get right into it it's a
summertime spaghetti salad
this is a salad that's actually a warm
salad i don't want to say hot salad
because
we're not serving it hot but it is warm
and we serve it before we put it in the
refrigerator but let's get right to it
so earlier i uh did some spaghetti just
according to the
the package directions now when you cook
pasta i beg you to please
follow the directions don't let it
overcook because overcooked pasta is
just just horrible so always keep a
timer on your pasta
that's one of my pet peeves so please do
that so i've got my al dente pasta ready
to go here's spaghetti
you could use any kind of pasta you like
in this situation but let's get right to
those fresh veggies
okay so what i have here is some corn
that i've grilled and taken off the cob
i have some tomatoes cherry tomatoes
and then i have some green beans that
are looking awesome and then i've got
some red onion
because that's a delicious thing to have
in any salt i think
we're going to need to dress this out so
let's make the dressing for it's a quick
vinaigrette
super easy just throw some things in a
blender i've got red wine vinegar
i've got olive oil i've got garlic
a little salt and pepper and sugar
actually help balance that
vinegariness and then some fresh thyme
and give that a spin
and can we let's go right there
that's all we've got that's done super
easy what i'm going to do with that now
is pour half of it onto my noodles and
half of it onto my veggies
this is just for a little bit easier
mixing
the oil in there helps these noodles
from sticking and then i'm going to do
my veggies
you can already tell that it's looking
fantastic and then i'm going to combine
smells are awesome it's fresh and what i
really love about this salad is the
colors you just
it just blows my mind just these awesome
colors okay and so
what i have here is some fresh basil
that i ripped with my hands
you can chop it if you like basil is
kind of a finicky herb
if you slice it and you keep it for too
long it can start to block it on you
so i'm just keeping keep that in mind
when you're making this so that's
fresh parm and then this is
pine nuts okay so this is our summertime
salad made with some fresh produce that
you either have in your garden you can
get from your local
smiths and really guys that is it let's
get this in our bowl
let's get some noodles in there and
let's get some this is great for any
potluck
summer barbecue holidays
just anytime really make it look pretty
i just love the way it looks and it
tastes fresh and it's delicious
okay that's it guys you can find all
these ingredients at your local smiths
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping and we will see you next
time bye-bye
for more information visit
smithsfoodanddrug.com and we will